so um today we're talking about the one
that got away or the one actually we'll
start with the one so tell me do you
guys believe in the in the one and tell
me why yes or no
you know what yeah yes I know
I'm a little bit I won't lie to you so
like I'll have the one for like a month
and then I'll be like he's not even all
that like why am I moving like this so
yeah yeah
I believe there's the one out there
I feel like obviously time is just the
essence so I feel like there's a
different time for everyone my best
friends Nan and Granddad have been
together for 58 years
May I'm Single Living my best life till
further notice but when it comes it
comes but I do believe it will come
I don't believe there's the one because
I think you could have multiple ones
so I feel like yeah I don't think
there's just one significant person so I
feel like in your lifetime you can have
more than one the one so how many your
ones have you had
you got
yeah it's been a few years now anyway
okay uh to be honest I feel like you
choose the one mm-hmm so yeah or they
choose you you meet that person that um
ticks with the boxes and then you just
say yep
you're good to go
yeah
um I tend to agree with him I think you
choose the one because um
I mean like especially in this day and
age is too much like we've got too much
choice and um
we can kind of like siphon out what we
want what we don't want you know we've
most of us have been around the block
enough to know like what we will
tolerating not tolerate so yeah
easy you're in the black big dog
what's that been around the block here
no no you sound like he's tired
you know I'm gonna be different I
believe in that there's the one
that one person there
even if there was a good person in your
life like 20 years ago
even if you're with a man or woman now
that person if I say the one that person
from way back when it sticks in your
brain folks that's the one I believe
there's one for everyone
I was lucky that I got my one I left my
one I got my one I with my one and how
is there a one for everyone if there's
55 if there's more women than men on the
planet it's 55 women 45 men maybe some
of them double up in it hang on a minute
look how many ones she had yeah I just
said I've got one she said she had
multiple ones I mean she's not good not
at the same time
yeah I mean we were talking about the
one and she was like yeah there's a one
this time I want that time one yeah
we're talking about V1 yeah she's got
five D ones right but that's how you
work it out it wouldn't be the one it's
not the one exactly but we were saying
the one that she had multiple you said
you said you believe in the one you
think there's something I do I believe
that how is how is there someone for
everyone if there's more women on the
planet than men if there's more women in
plant than men that means that some
people got more than one ones or they
got the same one
some girls have to share yes
but you don't know you might not know
I don't jump from a relationship I don't
jump from man I will know when it's the
right time I'm not talking about you
jumping for my man I'm talking about you
having the same man for about 10 years
he could be your one and then you find
that there's another woman that's been
out there 15 years and she is also
yeah so who's his woman that means
there's not one for everyone that means
it's kind of different to women some
people just miss out well you don't you
don't think like was that a term we hear
more for women or for men yeah but
that's what I'm saying women say like
he's the one but you don't hear men say
that because men are nasty they just
want a g and ski you think most men are
nasty what the woman women
say all men and nasty is be a lesbian
now if you're not a lesbian you can't
sit here and turn around and say that
old man
that you've had a nasty yeah
lesbians
that means that she's going to have
nasty men no that's that means she's
gonna now see me
she can't turn around here and sit down
and say that all men are nasty and
expect to have a man if you're gonna
turn around and say the old men are
nasty expect to have a woman because
that means that you don't want a man
because that man's gonna be nasty so as
you're gonna say that the minute she's
dealing with are nasty oh so many nasty
but I'm gonna sit here and let a woman
Jesus
you know what you gotta say that because
that means that he's nasty he's nasty
he's nasty he's nasty because foreign
most women are sexually active women are
more nasty than men by and large
it's because it's because women only
select a very small percentage of men on
dating apps we only swipe right five
percent of the time so the reason you
think men are trash is because you're
all sleeping with the same ones
humans are nately selfish and that's
what I'll say and that's what I mean by
not all humans
no no no no no no no no no no no
for me personally I feel like you can
have more than one soul mate in life
yeah but there's always the one like
there's always the one you can have more
than one soul mate but there's always
the one there's no plural there's always
like the one or maybe not always but if
you find the one there's just that one
and you know when you leave her in it
yeah when she's gone and ten years later
we can find another soul mate though but
you never remember the one they're not
yourself the one no there's a difference
there's a difference
you're cool if you're saying to someone
they're your soul mate that's like you
can get deeper than soulmate you can you
can get in one song
you can go into twin flames you could
get deep in and saw me trust me
you could get deeper than something
trust me look it up there's always the
one like whether she's in your life or
out your life even for women as well
like whether they're in your life
there's always that one
nah that's not yeah
okay what do you think so my my thing is
here I believe there's the one in it and
I'm gonna know when I get that one
because that one is gonna stop me from D
my dog and [ __ ] and I want to get dinner
because I love I love loving it you know
what I mean but at the moment I'm just
living but there's the one in it yeah
I'm saying but I'm just saying something
as well like what's her name sorry
what's your name man yeah Sharon you
need to slow down with calling every man
to stink back cause I know somebody I
know that's a stink bug in it I know
some good [ __ ] out there I know some
men that would die for the gallery
because you're young you're young yeah
you're younger you're still messing with
the little [ __ ] them that's that's
trying to run around and beat you in
your bedroom at the same time what
you're saying there's nothing wrong with
that man just trying to get there but
you see the thing is that what what you
like you you know sorry I I say this all
the time in it a lot of woman's got this
whole thing where they think they've
been watching Disney movies I think
that's life that's relationship that's
not relationship I ain't just women that
think that there's some men as well
I'm I'm a man I don't think like that
but okay we said somewhere but in order
to have a conversation we have to make
generalities and and who watches Disney
movies women or men yeah but then you're
getting that house so generalizing
saying that Madness
because because by and large men because
by and large men aren't nasty and
largely statistically there's no piece
of data that you can find out there that
says by and large men are nasty but he
didn't he didn't he didn't generalize
she said all
right he didn't say oh when he's talking
about Disney he didn't say oh she said
oh man
so out of the men and the women
I don't hear the men they're waiting for
their princess to come I'm always
hearing women talking about oh how many
frogs I have to kiss before I reach the
prince I never hear a man saying that
okay
no what we're trying to say is that
Disney don't work for men so when
they're saying about the women that gay
man you're talking about because I had
no man saying oh I'm waiting for my
princess to come away
for the queen queen ain't got nothing to
do with Disneyland
let me speak if you ask a black man yeah
about Queen got nothing to do with
Disney yeah nothing to do with Disney
and if you ask a black woman a better
place or something right oh whenever
this Frog's gonna come it's always
something to do with Disney but you will
never ever hear a black man say that he
wants a queen and an empress and to do
with Disney it's always tribals no but
you don't understand where it comes
comes from it don't come from Disney it
comes from the ancestor it comes from
Africa and that's what I'm talking about
when they when he's talking about the
girls and they're Disney they're waiting
for their prince to come and then they
turn around like the women normally do
it say oh what about the men the man's
doing it they call it a queen queen and
Disney come totally different in Disney
you got princess but you've never had a
man
you never hear a man talk about Princess
you always hear a man talk about his
Queen his Queen comes hang on a minute
actually
right and your hearing talking about his
Queen ain't got nothing to do with
Disney but you can't say that for
everyone
but how do you know
let me get wrong with you
talk about his Queen it's his black
queen everyone talk about this princess
it's his black princess and it comes
from Africa don't cover nothing to do
with Disney and there's somebody that
said they've got Rastafarians in go and
ask your father if he's talking about
his Queen if he mentions Disney
exactly but so when the men are talking
about Queen don't confuse it with Disney
she's talking about a prince will come
he's never heard that though listen
though you're talking about Disney he
said where you're coming from is Disney
she's bringing up the queen a queen for
a black person has nothing to do with
Disney if he's putting the woman there
he's one of the woman dead that's his
Queen that's his Emperor this is a
carry-on on his chest Disney man not
carry that they want a horse to carry
you they'll carry over the shoulder on
what the [ __ ] seven doors
sorry yeah so for me I've got a queen in
it the queen of this person that gave
birth to me in it my Empress is going to
be together you know what I'm saying yes
everything that I'm gonna settle down
within it but my I got my queen and my
queen Queen's my mother you know what
I'm saying that's nice
but you guys are watching too much
Disney things as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible